[Music]  hello everyone welcome to a tiring  Friday in my life I went to The  Institute at around 10 30 and I quickly  grabbed a coffee before I can rush to  the lab because I have to finish a lot  of experiment today  I started my day by sectioning some  mouse brain which I would be using for  immunohistochemistry analysis  it was a tiring and long experiment  however I mounted the slides and  processed them for immunohistochemistry  later that day I isolated RNA  and then I analyzed some of the data  spent some time on writing my thesis  also I analyzed some images that I have  recorded previously  it's time to go back I came back around  5 30 and went to the gym immediately  after that around seven I enjoyed the  sunset from my window and finished the  day with a swimming note